here is the mechanism of the
economic machine in 30 minutes to the economy
is a simple machine but
many people do not understand it or
do not agree it causes a
lot of unnecessary economic suffering
my sense of responsibility
encourages me to  share with you my
simple but practical economic model
it is unconventional but it has
helped me predict and survive the global
financial crisis
they have been dying in service for over 30
years starting the economy seems
complex but it is a mechanism  very
simple a
few components and a large number
of basic transactions repeated
billions of times these transactions
are above all managed by human beings
it generates three main forces
that make the economy go round
firstly productivity growth
secondly the debt cycle  short
term
third the site of
long term debt let's look at these three forces
and how their int  eractions chrtr
good model for tracking economic events
that we can achieve
understand let's start with the
simplest part of the economy
transactions
the economy is simply the sum
of all transactions
the notion of transactions is
relatively simple
we are constantly making transactions
transactions every time you
buy something it's a
transaction in every transaction
we have a buyer and a seller
exchanges of money or credit for
products, services or financial goods
credit is spent exactly
like money when you add up the money  and
the amount of credit spent and we
get the total amount disbursed
it is the total amount of spending
that drives the economy if we divide the
amount spent by the quantity sold
we get the price it's as simple
as that
the transaction  is the basic unit of the
economic machine
all the cycles and all the forces of
the economy are gener  ed by
transactions so if we understand
transactions we understand the economy
the market is made up of all the
buyers and all the sellers
transacting for the same
product eg the wheat market the
car market the stock market in  shopping and
other markets covering millions
of items the economy
consisting of all the transactions carried out
on all its markets
if we know the total expenditure and the
total quantity of sales on all the
markets
we then have all the elements
to understand the  economy
it's that
simple people businesses and banks
and governments all
transacted in this way it
exchanges money and credit for
products services or financial goods
largest buyer and
seller  and the government with these two
components a central government that
collects taxes and
spends money at a bank  e central which
makes it different from other buyers and
sellers as it thus controls the
amount of money and credit in
the economy by changing
interest rates and printing
central bank banknotes hence is one
of the most important decision makers of
credit flows let's take a closer look at credit
it is the most important part of
the economy is probably
the least understood the most important
because the biggest and most
unstable lenders and  borrowers
trade the same way as all
other buyers and
sellers lenders want to make
more money from what they have
and borrowers want to buy
something that they can afford a
house a car or else they
want to invest for example in
starting a
business credit is for both lenders
and borrowers to get what they
want borrowers promise to return the
amount borrowed  is called principal
plus another amount called
interest when interest rates are
high people borrow less because
it is expensive
when interest rates are low
they borrow more because it is
cheaper when the borrower promises to
repay and the lender
trusts him
the credit is established it is
simply created by two people
out of nothing it sounds simple but
the credit is misleading because they go by
different names as soon as the credit
is  strong but it becomes a debt
the debt is an asset for the lender and
a liability for the borrower
afterwards when the borrower
repays the loan plus interest
the asset and the liability disappear and the
transaction ends why the credit
is it so important
when the borrower receives the amount
borrowed he can increase his expenses
let's not forget that expenses
make the economy go round because the expenses
of a person constitute the  another's income
every dollar you spend
is earned by someone else
and every dollar you earn has been
spent by someone else
if you spend more
someone else earns more money  if
someone's income increases
lenders willingly lend
him money because he is considered
creditworthy a creditworthy borrower
has two characteristics the
ability to repay and
collateral having a high income
relative to the secured debt  the ability
to repay it
if the borrower cannot repay
his assets serve as collateral
they can be seized and sold
so lenders have no reluctance
to lend him money
higher incomes allow for
larger borrowings and his
prints allow to spend
more since the flax tusks
are the income of the other it allows
even more important loans this
phenomenon of reinforcement leads to the
growth é  economic
and this is how cycles begin
in a transaction
you have to give something to
get something
is what you get is proportional to
what you produce over time you
learn and the accumulated knowledge
allows us to improve  our standard
of living
is called
productivity growth those of us who
are inventive and hard working
increase our productivity and
standard of living faster than those who
are passive and lazy but this is not
not always true in the short
term productivity is important especially in the
long term and credit issues in the
short term
the reason for this is that productivity growth
varies little and is therefore not
an important factor in
economic fluctuations debt on the contrary
allows us to consume more than we
produce when we contract it
and then forces us to consume less
than we produce when we
repay it  Debt fluctuations
follow two main cycles one lasts
between 5 and 8 years and the other lasts between 75 and
years most people when they
feel the fluctuations do
n't see them as cycles because it voices
them too closely  day to day or
week to week
in this chapter we are going to take a
step back and look at these three great
forces their interaction is their
influence on our lives we have already
said that fluctuations are not due
to innovation or quality  of
work
they are mainly due to the
volumes of existing credits
let's imagine for a moment an economy without
credit in this economy if I am going to
increase my expenses the only way is
to increase my income
that is to say that I must become more
productive and work more
growth can only come from an
increase in productivity but
spending so much their coming from
someone else
the growth of the economy depends on the
growth of  e productivity
if we observe transactions
and extrapolate we see a
progression similar to productivity growth
but as we borrow
we have cycles these cycles do not
result from any law or regulation they
are due to human nature and that
credit
borrow it's like stretching out your
expenses into the future to buy
something I can't
afford I have to spend more than
I earn for it I'm
essentially committing my future earnings
so I'm creating a future in which I
should spend less than what i
earn in order to repay mrs hadad
it quickly takes a
cyclical turn simply every
time i borrow i create a cycle it is
true of both people and
the economy this is for this  why it
is so important to understand the concept
of credit because it is what triggers
the predictable mechanism of
future economic events it is this that
makes credit  says different from money money
allows you to settle transactions
when you buy a beer
with cash
the a3 in creysse in xavi mediately but
if you buy your beer on credit
you create a slate
you promise to pay  later you
and the bartender create an asset and a liability
you made credit out of
nothing
the asset and liability will
only disappear when you have paid
off the debt the debt is gone
and the transaction is complete
which most of the  people
call money is actually credit the
total amount of credit in the united states
is about 50 million dollars
compared to almost 3 only for the
total amount of money
remember that in an economy without
credit  the only way to increase
spending is to produce more
but in an economy with loan one
can increase spending by borrowing
in an economy with credit one spends
more in the short term their income  they
grow faster than
productivity but not in the long term
despite this credit is not
necessarily a bad thing forcing
cycles it is bad when they
finance excessive consumption than
being reimbursed it is good when it
distributes resources in a
relevant way  and proceeds from the income which
allows you to repay the debt
for example if you borrow to
buy a bigger
television set this does not generate any income
allowing you to repay the debt
but if you borrow to buy a
tractor and this tractor insures you
better harvests therefore better
income you will be able to pay off your
debt and improve your standard of living
in a credit economy we
can follow the thread of transactions
and see how credit allows
growth
let me give you an example if
you earn 100 thousand dollars  per year and
that you have no debt,
we are ready to grant you a loan of
10 thousand dollars for example on your
credit card so
you can spend 110 thousand
dollars even if you have earned 100
thousand your expenses constituting their
coming from someone else
somewhere someone garnishing 10000
dollars
this person earning 110 thousand  dollars
and having no debt can borrow
eleven thousand dollars and can therefore spend
121 thousand dollars
even having earned only 110 thousand
dollars his expenses constitute
came to them from someone else and
following the thread of transactions we
begin to  understand the process
of self reinforcement but let's not forget
that borrowing goes through cycles and
after a phase of growth
inevitably comes a decline this is the cycle
of short term debt economic activity
increases we see an
expansion
this is the first phase of the
short term debt cycle defense rises
and prices with it as
increased spending is fueled by credit
credit  it that is created out of nothing
when the volume of expenditure and
income increases faster than
that of production prices go up
when prices go up
this is called inflation the
central bank does not want  too
much inflation
because it causes problems
when prices rise the bank
raises interest rates when
interest rates are higher fewer
people can afford to borrow and
the cost of existing debt rises
imagine the  monthly payment on your
credit card going
up people borrow less but have to
pay back more
they have less money available
so expenses go down
and like linen expenses are
each other's income income goes down
too and so on when people
spend
less prices go down it's deflation
economic activity goes down and we
have a recession when the recession
gets extreme and inflation is no
longer a pro  problem
the central bank lowers
interest rates to restart the process
with lower interest rates
debt repayment and
reduce borrowing and spending resumes and
we have a new expansion
you can see the economy is working
like a machine in the short
term cycle spending is limited only
by the willingness of lenders and
borrowers to provide and receive
credit when credit is available
the economy is expanding
when credit is not available
l  economy is in a recession
note that this cycle is controlled
mainly by the central bank
the cycle of short term debt lasts
between five and eight years and is
constantly repeated but note that the
maximum is the minimum of each cycle
are characterized by a  growth and
more debt than in the previous cycle
why because people are
pushing we tend to borrow
and spend more instead  that to
repay our debts
it is in human nature for this
reason over long periods
the debt increases faster than
their income thus forming the cycle of
long term
debt despite the increasing indebtedness of people
the lenders their agreement more
easily credit why because
we are all convinced that all is
well people only focus on
recent events and what is
the latest news incomes have
increased the value of financial assets are
increasing and the stock market and prosperous we
are growing
the  buying products, services or
financial assets with borrowed money
becomes profitable
when this trend becomes widespread
we call it a bubble even though the
debt only grows their income
grows almost as fast and
offsets the ratio of debt
to income s  'call the weight of debt
as long as their income continues to
grow the weight of debt remains  e
manageable
at the same time the value of
financial assets skyrockets people
borrow heavily to buy
assets as an investment which pushes
up their prices even more
people feel rich
even when accumulating debt
the increase  income and the value
of financial assets allow
borrowers to remain solvent for a
long time
but this situation cannot last
indefinitely
one day it ceases for decades
the debt burden has increased
slowly repayments have
become heavier at some point
repayment of debt grows
faster than their
income people are forced to reduce
spending the expenditure of the ain constituting
the income of the other income
begins to fall which makes
people less creditworthy and slows down
borrowing repayments  of debt
continues to grow, which
further reduces expenditure and the cycle is reversed,
the peak of the debt is exceeded.  long-
term debt the debt burden has become
too heavy for the united states europe
and most countries
all this happened in 2008 for the
same reason that it happened to japan in
1989 and the united states in 1929
the economy is going into a
deleveraging
phase people are cutting back on
spending income is falling credit is
disappearing the prices of financial goods are
collapsing the banks are in dire straits the
stock market is panicking social tensions are
rising and the whole process is starting up again
in reverse  income
decreases debt repayments increase
borrowers are stuck they are no
longer creditworthy credit is crumbling
and borrowers can no longer
borrow enough money to repay
their debts
to make up for this shortfall borrowers
are forced to sell property flooding
thus the market at the same time as the
expenses decrease
it is then that the stock
market collapses the real estate market where the banks
are in diff  iculty
the price of goods and the value of
collateral plummet borrowers
become even less creditworthy
people feel poor credit is
rapidly disappearing
less spending less income
less wealth - credit - borrowing and
so on it's a  vicious circle
it looks like a recession but the
difference is that you can't lower
interest rates to solve the
problem in a recession
lowering interest rates to
stimulate borrowing but in a period of
deleveraging this approach  is futile
because interest rates are already low
almost 1 0% and the stimulus effect
no longer exists interest rates in
the united states were at 0% during the
deleveraging of the 1930s is
again in 2008 the difference  between
recession and deleveraging and that in
times of deleveraging the debt burden
has become too heavy for
borrowers and that they cannot be
relieved by lowering interest rates on
loans  lenders understand that the debts
are too heavy to
ever be repaid borrowers have
lost their ability to repay and
their collateral is worthless they
are crippled by debt and no
longer want to borrow lenders
stop lending borrowers
stop borrowing  think of an economy that
is no longer solvent
exactly like an individual where
the deleveraging is
the problem is that the weight of the debt
is too heavy and that we must reduce
it there are four ways to do it
firstly individuals the
businesses and governments
reduce spending
second reduce debt by
restructuring it third
redistribute wealth from the haves
to the have-nots
fourth the central bank
print money
these four methods have been used in
every deleveraging in modern history
we begin  in general by reducing
expenses individuals
businesses banks  es and even the
government is using the belt
reduce spending to be able to
pay off the debt this
is called austerity if
borrowers stop taking on
new debt and pay off the
old one would
expect the debt burden to decrease  but in
reality that reverses
if we reduce the expenditure and the
expenditure of one and the income of the other
the income decreases more quickly
than the repayment of the debt and the
weight of the debt becomes even heavier
we have already seen  that these
austerity measures are deflationary and
painful businesses need to
cut spending which means
fewer jobs therefore more unemployment
the next step is the obligation to
reduce debt many borrowers
are unable to repay their
debts and the  borrower's debt
is the lender's asset when
borrowers cannot
repay banks
bank customers wonder if
the bank  ue will be able to return their money
and is rushing to empty their accounts
the banks are dry and the
individuals the companies and the
banks can no longer meet the
deadlines
this severe economic contraction is
a depression
a major factor in the depression and
that people are discovering  that their
wealth was fictitious come back to the bar if
you buy a stone and inscribed it
on oise art you promise to
repay the bartender your promise
becomes his asset but if you do
n't keep your promise if you don't
repay it is not  your slate
is worthless the bartender's asset is
worthless it just disappeared
rather than giving up their asset
many lenders agree to
restructure the debt
this means the lender will not receive
the full amount or they  will be paid in the
longer term at a lower interest
rate than provided for in
the original contract and terminate in a
manner that reduces the debt
the lenders preferred to collect
less money than none even if the
debt disappears restructuring
cuts bank income and
assets faster debt burden only
gets worse reducing debt is
as painful and deflationary
as cutting spending
central government to  in turn
collects less taxes due to the
reduction in income and employment at the
same time the state must increase
spending to reduce unemployment
a large number of unemployed do not have
enough savings and the government
must
help more it must create stimulating projects
and increases its spending to
compensate for the downturn in the economy
the government spends more than it
collects in taxes and gets bogged down in a
debt reduction program it is the
budget deficit that we  talk to the
news to finance the
deficit governments need to increase the
news or borrow money but in
a situation of reduced income and
unemployment where will the money come from  ent of the rich
government needs more
money capital is concentrated in the hands
of a
few government naturally seeks to
tax the rich which facilitates the
redistribution of wealth from the haves
to the less privileged
who are in difficult circumstances and who  jealous
the better off the better off stressed
by a weakened economy and by the
devaluation of their property for sale to the
less privileged
if the depression continues the
social structure breaks down not only does
tension rise in the country
but there is a risk of an international escalation,
particularly between
countries  lenders and borrowing countries this
situation can lead to
sometimes extreme political change in the 1930s
we had the rise to power of hitler
the war in europe the depression in
the united states the need for a solution to
end the depression becomes acute
and what most people thought
was money was actually c  repeat
so if the credit disappears people
no longer have enough money
the need for money is made desperate and
that a price of money the central bank
once the interest rates are almost
zero it is forced to
printing money contrary to an
austerity policy of debt reduction and
redistribution of wealth
printing money causes inflation and stimulates
the process inevitably
more money has to be printed without
any real basis and  use it to
buy financial assets and government
bonds like in the united states
during the great depression or
again in 2008 when the american central bank
the federal reserve
printed more than 2 trillion dollars
the other central banks that
could also have printed money
by buying financial goods with
this money they raised the
price of goods which allows people
to obtain credit
but this is only useful to those who
have  ent of financial goods
the fact is that the central bank can
print money but it can only
buy financial goods the
central government on the other hand can
buy goods and services and
put money in the hands of
individuals but  it can't
print money so to stimulate
the economy
the two have to cooperate the
central bank buys the bridges the state
so lends money to the government
which allows it to be in deficit
to increase the  spending to continue to
acquire goods and services
through stimulus programs and
to pay benefits to the unemployed
individual incomes and
government debt increase but this
decreases the total burden of debt on
the economy
these actions are risky
policy makers need to find a
balance between the four elements
of the debt burden
we need to balance deflation and
inflation to maintain some
balance
if we do  t correctly
deleveraging can be harmonious
this process can be completely
failed or perfectly harmonious
how can deleveraging be
harmonious even if it is a
difficult situation finding an
optimal solution to it is
more genius than excesses of  'a phase
of malik debt is free and in a
harmonious deleveraging the debt is
reduced in proportion to income
real and positive economic growth
and inflation is no longer a
problem
it results from a good balance this
balance requires a certain cocktail
austerity and debt reduction
wealth transfer
and bank note printing
maintaining economic and social stability
people are wondering about
printing money on it cause inflation it
won't happen it's  is inflation
compensates for loss of credit remember
it's all about spending 1
dollar spent in the form of money has the
same effect on prices as  'a dollar
spent on credit by
printing money the central bank compensates for the
disappearance of credit with an
increase in the volume of money to
turn the tide
the central bank must not only
encourage income growth but
also ensure that the
growth rate of income is higher than
the interest rate on accumulated debt
that all this simply means
that income must grow
faster than debt
for example suppose a country in the process
of deleveraging or with a
debt to income ratio of  100%
this means that the debt is equal to the
total income of the whole country in one year
assume an interest rate of 2% on
this debt
if the debt increases at a rate of 2% and the
income at a rate of 1%  only
we can never reduce the weight of the
debt
we must print enough money so that
the rate of growth of income exceeds
the rate of interest however we
quickly exceed the limits because
printing money  ent is an easy fix that
people prefer to other measures
the secret is to avoid printing
too much and thus causing unacceptable inflation
like germany
did in the 1920s if
policy makers strike a balance
correct deleveraging is going well
growth is slow but debt burden
decreases and deleveraging is
successful when their incomes start
to rise borrowers seem more
creditworthy in this situation
lenders agree to
lend money again
the weight of  debt finally begins to
decline when they can
borrow people spend more the
economy grows again
thus entering the reflation phase
of the long-term debt cycle
the process of deleveraging can be
terrible if done wrong  is
well managed it can finally solve the
problem it takes a little more than
ten years to eliminate the weight of the
debt and restart the activity  economic ity
that's why we talk about a
lost decade obviously the economy is a little
more complex than this model
suggests the superposition of the
short-term head cycle on the site of
long-term debt
then seven cycles  on
the productivity growth curve
allows us to fully understand where we are
where we were and where we are going
in conclusion I recommend three
rules of conduct to adopt
firstly do not let your debt
grow faster than your income
because the weight of  debt will eventually
crush you secondly don't let
income grow faster than
productivity because you will no longer be
competitive and thirdly do
your best to increase your
productivity because in the long run
that's what matters most these
simple tips s  applies to
individuals as well as decision makers
you have no idea how
little attention most people including decision makers pay enough attention to these
elements
this model has always done me a favor and
i hope it helps you too thank you
and